do that when you have X to the negative
end power that's equivalent to 1 over X
to the positive n right so let's see how
we can utilize this formula to help us
so first of all let's take a look at
this 1 X to the negative 2 so if we use
the formula this is just saying 1 over X
to the positive 2 and we're done okay
let's take a look at another example
we've got 1 over Y to the negative 3 now
when you look at this you could simplify
it as saying okay Y to the negative 3
that's 1 over Y to the positive 3 but
then when we divide by a fraction it's
the same thing as taking the numerator
and then multiplying by the reciprocal
because dividing is the same thing as
multiplying by the reciprocal right so
this is really like multiplying by Y
cubed over 1 all I did was take the
denominator and flip it now when we
multiply we get Y cubed over 1 which is
just Y cubed now that's a lot of work
and that's absolutely not necessary all
you have to do is when you see a
negative exponent okay or a quantity
with a negative exponent all you have to
do is just move it to the other side of
the fraction bar so if it's a negative
and it's down in the denominator
go ahead and move it into the numerator
and make it a positive exponent
same thing with this one you can think
of x to the negative 2 as over 1
anything divided by 1 is itself so by
moving this to the denominator and
making it a positive exponent you've
taken care of that negative exponent so
you just want positive exponents in your
final answer so let's so get some more
challenging examples like this one over
here so what you can do is just like
when you simplify fractions ordinarily
you can look at the numbers okay just
like a fraction and the integers and you
can just simplify this like 2 goes into
2 once 2 goes into 8 4 times so we've
just reduced this to a 1/4 right and
then just like we were talking about
earlier we've got X to the negative 3
let's move that to the other side of the
fraction bar make that X to the positive
3 here we've got Z to the negative 2
let's move that to the numerator and
make that Z to the positive 2 and then Y
to the 5th that already has a positive
exponent so we're just gonna leave it
where it's at in the numerator Y to the
5th
now just one quick note a lot of times
when students see the negative exponent
they think to themselves oh that makes
the number negative and you don't want
to make the
negative you just want to take the
reciprocal so to show you another
example along that same lines like say
for example if you had two X to the
negative two Y cubed all to the negative
third power right so what you could do
is you could take this negative three
and you're going to distribute it okay
to each of these terms now this is just
a monomial just one term so you just
raise everything to that negative third
power now you don't see it but this is
really like two to the first power power
to a power we multiply so one times
negative three gives you two to the
negative third okay native two times
three gives you X to the sixth and three
times negative three gives you Y to the
negative ninth now all we have to do is
think of that as being divided by one
anything over one or divided by 1 is
itself so now anything that has a
negative exponent we're just going to
move it to the other side of the
fraction bar and make it a positive
exponent so this is going to end up
being let's see X to the sixth over two
to the third power y to the ninth power
2 cubed is two times two times two or
three times so that comes out to X to
the sixth over eight Y to the ninth okay
let's look at one more example this one
here same thing we're going to work with
the numbers we're going to work with the
X's together as a group and we're look
at the Y's together as a group so here
we're just going to reduce these we can
see that 2 goes into 50 25 times 2 also
goes into 12 6 times we've reduced it
okay now here when you divide you
subtract so you take the numerators
power minus the denominators power so
negative 7 minus 4 which is negative 11
and you put that result in the numerator
okay so this is the quotient rule when
you divide you subtract the exponents
same thing here with the Y is negative 2
minus negative 3 is like adding 3 so
that's going to be Y to the first ok so
we're almost done when we just want
positive exponents in that final answer
so we're going to take this quantity
here we're going to move it to the other
side of the fraction bar so that gives
us 25 y to the first or you could just
say Y okay
divided by 6 X to the 11th power and
that's your final answer so we just have
positive exponents we reduced as much as
we we could there and that's it so I
hope this helped you to understand how
to work with negative exponents a little
bit more efficiently and easily
subscribe
to the channel check out some more math
videos on my channel Mario's math
tutoring YouTube channel and I look
forward to seeing in the future videos
I'll talk to you soon